that's kind of gotten to the point where
i can't work anywhere else
i guess i'm a bit superstitious
so you're a writer
guilty yeah
but i know anything you've written
if i
told you my pen name you know possibly
but i barely know you
i believe in superstition too when you
believe in superstition seriously there
is a whole section in my dissertation
dedicated to dissertation oh my god know
what field
um
it's called noetic science
i'm a research assistant and we are
looking for proof of parapsychological
phenomena so that's the mind-body
connection
the whole spiritual healing gamut are
you serious
the book i'm writing is all about
parapsychology
what i swear to god you you wouldn't
happen to know catherine solomon by any
chance would you
um
yes actually she's my boss she's your
boss yep
i saw her earlier today in fact you saw
her today
where
oh no i you know i've just read a lot of
her work doing research for my latest
book right she did this study on
indigo children it was really
fascinating
i assisted that study no way
hey could i buy you another cup of
coffee i mean if you have time
sure
uh
how about a glass of wine instead
i love that yeah sure okay
oh my i cannot believe i just did that
i'm so sorry oh it's nothing i'll just
i'm gonna go clean up quick
needless to say the wine's on me okay
deal
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you